[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt eine ganz
besondere torte vom blech nämlich ein
spiegelei blechkuchen und eigentliche
spiegel herzhaft aber heute gibt es eine
optische täuschung denn unsere
spiegeleier sind richtig schön süß und
wir bereiten jetzt zuallererst den teig
zu und dafür zeige ich euch jetzt die
zutaten
wir benötigen mehr außer dem backpulver
eine prise salz etwas zucker
orangenlimonade rapsöl und eier sowie
fahrer in diese ganz einfach alle
zutaten sich gerade gezeigt habe zu
einem rührteig habe ich schon eine große
schüssel und mein handrührgerät aber das
geht auch ganz einfach mit dem schnee
bilden also für dieses rezept braucht
ihr eigentlich gar keine maschine und
die stadt jetzt zuallererst mit dem
trockenen zutaten also mehl backpulver
prise salz und zucker und dann gebe ich
die flüssigen zutaten mit dazu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wo der tag ist auch schon fertig also es
geht nicht darum mit dem teig sonderbar
irgendwie auch zu schlagen sondern
einfach nur zusammen zur in und deshalb
reicht wie gesagt auch der schneebesen
und jetzt nimmt ihr euch euer backblech
dann nehme ich jetzt hier das tiefe habe
ein backpapier untendrunter gelegt und
dann führen wir den tag ein und dann
wird auch schon gebacken ich verstreicht
es immer noch schön glatt und jetzt
kommt in den vorgeheizten backofen bei
180 grad für 20 minuten und wir bereiten
der zwischenzeit die creme vor
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die creme benötigen wir mit
speisestärke zucker etwas vanille zucker
und doppel ram frischkäse
es gibt weiter am herd und jetzt kochen
wir eine art pudding auf wenn ihr jetzt
alle zutaten bis auf den doppeln
frischkäse und geben den in den topf
aber den hat noch nicht einschalten
sondern erst alles klümpchen frei
verrühren und haben sie das stück heute
muss ich sagen kannst dir nicht
vorstellen denn warte mal ab jetzt magic
[Musik]
sobald wir dann alles kirchen frei
verrückt einfach den herr einschalten
und dann einmal aufkochen lassen und
sobald es auf kocht ein dickes auch
schon ein und dann fühlen wir das auch
schon um das dauert wirklich alles nur
ein bis zwei minuten also schön bei der
sache bleiben und immer fleißig umrühren
und den pudding jetzt direkt an der
oberfläche ab damit sich keine haus
bildet und dann lassen wir den pudding
vollständig abkühlen dann gebe ich jetzt
ganz einfach für eine halbe stunde in
den kühlschrank so beschleunige ich dass
etwas und danach werden wir erst den
doppel ram frischkäse der kuchen ist
aufgerufen haben sich jetzt vorüber
schwenken
das ist der kuchen der ist auch schon
gar nicht ob die stäbchen probe gemacht
schön goldbraun und unser pudding ist
eine zwischenzeit auch abgekühlt das
heißt es niemals ganz einfach die folie
ab ohne dass noch mal ein bisschen schön
locker aber dass so ein bisschen auch
mit dem schneebesen und dann kommt unser
doppel ram frischkäse dazu und das
bildet dann das eiweiß um spiegel aber
das zeige ich euch gleich
[Musik]
so jetzt geht es los mit dem spaßigen
teil wobei prinzip macht generell spaß
und ich finde es ist auch ein rezept für
kinder weil es total einfach geht und
die keine aufwändigen maschinen braucht
aber wie gesagt machen wir jetzt weiter
mit dem spiegelei und zwar ist das unser
eiweiß und das geben wir jetzt ganz
natürlich wie ganz natürlich ist auf den
kuchen und backen das dann noch mal aber
dazu komme ich gleich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sobald dann das eiweiß schön verstrich
wurde also jeweils in anführungszeichen
eher werden wir sind noch mal backen
benehmt euch vorstellen müssen jetzt
etwas fester werden damit wie sie später
schön dekorieren können und deshalb
kommt das ganze bei gleicher hitze also
180 grad ober und unterhitze erneut in
den backofen für zehn minuten und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder wenn alles
abgekühlt ist
[Musik]
den google habe ich gerade aus dem ofen
geholt und jetzt zeige ich euch hier
vorne mal die zutaten für die restliche
dekoration dafür benötigen wir aprikosen
hier habe ich den saft aufgefangen
außerdem ag habe ich noch pistazien fein
gehackt und etwas später kuvertüre
lingus vorzubereiten nehmen und den sagt
aprikosen ist ja schon gesüßt weil die
aprikosen aus der dose auch schon mit
zucker sind deshalb verzichte ich hier
auf weitere zucker wenn ihr das möchtet
könnt ihr das natürlich gerne noch
hinzufügen und ich gebe den saft jetzt
in meine top koch das jetzt noch nicht
auf da gebe ich jetzt agger dazu das ist
20 uhr ermitteln
ihr könntet stadt das natürlich auch
klaren torten berufsverbänden nach
packungsanleitung dass es euch
überlassen
und jetzt ganz einfach verrühren und
dann aufkochen und das ganze muss in
zwei minuten köcheln und dann ist auch
schon fertig
der bus ist fertig bekommt doch sofort
zum einsatz aber es fehlen ja munter
eigelbe und die haben wir hier in dieser
dose und da gebe ich jetzt einfach immer
ein eigelb auf das eiweiß und dann gehen
wir den tortenguss obendrauf
[Musik]
und die sektoren wo es ja nur gepresst
werden dafür gebe ich jetzt für eine
halbe stunde in den kühlschrank oder er
lässt es ganz langsam auf
zimmertemperatur auswerten das ist auch
kein problem und danach sehen ja nur
noch leckere kräuter für unser leckeres
spiegelei und das machen wir hier in
form von unseren pistazien und wer mag
der kann noch so ein bisschen pfeffer
dazugeben natürlich keine echten sondern
unsere zartbitter kuvertüre ganz einfach
drüberfahren rast bild aber wir haben
hier auch schon vanillezucker im pudding
und das ist auch schon vier phase wenn
ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr auch
doppeltreffer verwenden ganz euch
überlassen
das sieht aus und weißt du was du jetzt
dazu braucht eigentlich hansa rostock
droht der spiegel ein vielleicht kann
sich nicht richtig cool aus das schmeckt
auch super lecker durch die
orangenlimonade im teilte das ganze
richtig schön fluffig nicht nur durch
den geschmack sondern auch durch die
kohlensäure als auf keinen fall darauf
verzichten und die creme den aprikosen
wunderbar macht unbedingt nach die
genauen mengenangaben schreibe ich euch
wie immer hier unten in die infobox
ich gehe jetzt damit so mutter und
schwiegermutter und überrascht die man
so ein bisschen und die werden bestimmt
sagen und was machst du später auf
kuchen das geht nicht die kriegen
bestimmten schock aber mal schauen und
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß im
nachbacken ob es dann im ausland genießt
oder einfach so zum kaffee mit meiner
liebsten schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare wenn es nach gemacht habt und
dann freue ich mich wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten mal einschaltet auf die skizzen
tschüss
[Musik]